dice grasso parla fa finta di niente
ti sei preparato a 12 ore sarai
sicuramente perfetta che è tutto a posto
un po di profumo di risanamento
ciao scusa mi sono scese a buttare la
spazzatura
scusami festa un po in disordine sai di
solito mi tira un po di più per riuscire
[Musica]
rottame ok marina ce la puoi fare
spalle indietro mette davanti un piede
dopo l'altro e nuovi la mano come la
regina elisabetta per salutare sei la
migliore dritta drittissima pertanto
marina tiranti sua è la gobba dai sei
giovane dai mari cantaci qualcosa
no dai mi vergogno dai un pezzettino
della tua canzone
figurati nota va bene per l'estate che
mi perdo ma non fa abbastanza accanto se
non sai come basta oramai ami sporche
lontano tutti siamo date e alzate chiami
prendo ma lo fa lo stronzo a caldo se
non sei è dato lontano davvero ma
davvero veramente divertente questa
storia
no
[Musica]
io mi rode tantissimo al naso come
faccio a far finta di niente
oddio ancora tanti inizio
[Musica]
ok
buonissima
come dissi ma questa piazza è piena
[Musica]